i i want to begin the reflection on
addiction by
um
understanding from the standpoint of the
12-step recovery program for addiction
what the turning point is
in the life of the addict
and and the turning point is the point
at which they hit bottom
and they hit bottom is for them a crisis
in which they're able to see for
themselves the bankruptcy of their
strategies
that they don't really have a problem
they can handle it they get out of it it
isn't and they just see this completely
false
and they're able to see for themselves
that this addictive use of the substance
they're addicted to
is destroying them
and they can also see
that they're powerless to stop
so the crisis is for them
kind of an existential crisis
that is if this is up to them they're
finished
they're finished so if they don't resort
back to denial they're only faced with
despair
if it's up to them unless there's
another way
unless there's another way and the other
way
is that maybe it isn't
ultimately up to them at all that maybe
there's a power greater than themselves
that can achieve in them
the freedom from the addiction that they
by them by their own powers are
powerless to achieve that's the other
way
and so the very beginning then is a kind
of a faith
and really the faith is freedom from the
addiction
of the perception of oneself is
absolutely isolated all on one's own
having to make it on one's own terms
and this faith kind of begins to break
open that addiction
to this radically different way of
experiencing themselves but i'm in a
relationship with a mystery greater than
myself
that the mystery greater than myself is
in a relationship with me and my hope
lies in that relationship
and
this relationship
with the mystery greater than myself
in order to be in order for it to be
actualized
i have to hand my life over to the care
of that higher power
i can't have it both ways
i can't say theoretically there is this
presence but i'm still going to try to
make it
i have to hand my life over to the care
of the higher power who can achieve in
me what i can't achieve
and so this starts them on this path
they concretize that through a fearless
inventory to the making of amends
is concretized in the faith community of
recovery that they bear witness that
this is real
they move through it it gravitates
toward the 11th step of increasing
conscious contact with god
and in that process the person says to
their higher powers they go through this
painful messy process they say to their
higher power i don't know who you are
but i do know who you are you're the one
who saved my life
and i don't know who i am i do know
you're the one i'm saved
and so there's this intimate
radicalization
of how one experiences one's life
and brings one to this new state of
consciousness
for which one is immensely grateful and
wants to pass it on to others
so we might say that's the first level
of what you could think of as the
spirituality of
freedom from addiction you